autres titres de l'actualité
internationale cette catastrophe évitée
de près de peu à ça porridge assez le
président volodymyr zelensky qu'il dit
pour la première fois de son histoire la
centrale nucléaire s'est partiellement
retrouvé déconnectés du réseau s'est
retrouvée totalement déconnecté pendant
quelques heures en cause des dommages
sur les lignes électriques selon kiev le
gouverneur de zaporizhya vient
d'annoncer je vous le disais que deux
réacteurs ont repris un fonctionnement
normal on en parle avec virginie herz
l'envoyé spécial de france 24 à kiev
bonjour à vous virginie avez vous plus
de précision là dessus
oui effectivement l'alertent était
absolument maximale depuis depuis hier
et hier soir
l'incident semblait ce premier incident
semblait clos on attendait effectivement
la reconnexion totale du réacteur 1 au
système électrique ukrainien parce qu'au
delà du risque de au delà du risque du
terrain en tant que telle la question
autour de zaporizhya c'est de savoir
ciney centrales peuvent fournir les de
l'électricité à l'ukraine vous savez que
cette centrale fournit en temps normal
20% de l'électricité à l'ukraine et
s'est véritablement ça l'enjeu qui va se
jouer dans les semaines à venir et
notamment en vue en plus de l'hiver les
autorités ukrainiennes soupçonne les
russes de vouloir détourner
l'électricité vers la crimée le
le vix le directeur général par dons de
lait à hyères se disait extrêmement
préoccupé et pas essayer de monter une
délégation une visite sur ce centre ça
devrait avoir lieu dans les jours qui
viennent mais là encore rien bras de fer
diplomatique les russes ne veulent vous
souhaiteraient que cette visite se fasse
en passant par la russe tea party par la
russie pour d'une certaine façon valider
le fait que cette zone aux alentours de
la centrale de zappos ridja est
maintenant contrôlée par par le côté pro
russe et donc que ça peut poser problème
du côté ukrainien donc en tout cas ce
qu'on peut dire c'est que le risque que
l' alerte maximale et baissé et que le
bras de fer qui se joue maintenant c'est
celle de la visite de l'agoa et les
conditions de cette visite et virginie
herz envoyée spéciale de france 24 à
kiev en ukraine merci beaucoup à vous
pour ces dernières informations